moi j'ai toujours rêvé je fais du
théâtre pour être sacha guitry whisky
est impossible alors je m'étais j'avais
pris mon pseudonyme je m'appelais je
m'appelais michel livry vous voyez ça ça
c'est un projet et puis alors je
j'écrivais des pièces mais ces pièces je
m'étais le titre je m'étais le nombre
d'actes je signais bon nom de milliers
de livres et puis ça ça s'arrêtait là
mais j'aurais aimé berges m'acheter des
petites bagues voyez à monoprix parce
que sacha qui avait deux bagues alors je
prenais des parcs comme je n'ai pas
d'argent je prenais des bagues à 20
francs monoprix je vous rappelle qu'ils
éteignaient ça donnait tout noir en
dessous mais alors je me régale et
j'avais mis deux banques j'ai encore
acheté une bague il n'ya pas longtemps
là quand je suis là venise alors c'est
de là maintenant comme j'ai des moyens
plus fortes vagues mais moi je me suis
rendu compte très vite évidemment que ça
va je faisais tout de suite un petit peu
un petit peu vulgaire un petit peu voyez
un petit peu cheap au maquereau comme ça
quand je porte une bague alors qu'est-ce
que les gens alors j'enlève parce que
quand même temps en temps je me dis non
mais mais c'est une sensation la bague
doit d'ailleurs demandé ça sperme
abandonné tous les comédiens ou les
chanteurs encore on débat godoy la bague
au doigt alors acquis qu'on monte quand
on lève le bras voyons voit la balle
c'est beau perdant sacha guitry laver
les manchettes jusqu'à j'ai pas de
chemise pour passer de 9 ans venu
spécialement imaginé que j'ai une bague
et puis alors je peux commencer
mon dieu mon dieu de voile à 1 c'était
le voyez finale se régaler avec cet
homme tout le temps tout le temps je me
suis régalé même encore maintenant voyez
s'il me tombe un truc de sacha guitry
jeu j'en ai pour la journée je vais sur
sa tombe
moi c c je suis dès que j'ai eu un peu
de cafard entre la lecture de sacha
guitry me remettre tout de suite en
place j'adore je sais me donne une
sensation extraordinaire cet homme oui
tu as toujours une pulsation aussi
rapide à ça je sais pas moi je ne je ne
compte plus un joli tailleur sur je
n'arrive pas à me trouver des maisons
mais l'homme mais à mon avis si tu me
fais une vie une bonne arrivée il me
paraît mais demi
c'est ennuyeux ça c'est non non j'en ai
c'est le tabac mais je ne fume pas pour
moi j'ai arrêté j'ai deux enchères et et
je ne fume pas et c'est déjà une
information oui diront si tu n'as jamais
une douleur à l'épaule gauche
la corée puis dans la quant à puce et
douloureux le comique que c'est un
réflexe de peur
d'abord c'est le ses basques et le drame
le comique en général mais c'était aussi
un réflexe de peur de timidité et
et les timides sont des gens qui skie
très gêné toujours en société on se sont
entraînés systématiquement parce qu'ils
pouvaient pas faire autrement pour
s'échapper à faire des choses drôles ou
s'en sortir par des galipettes parce que
alors s'ils sont doués ils s'en sortent
s'ils sont pas doués c'est la
catastrophe évidemment messi sont doués
s'en sort parce que je me souviens
toujours que j'avais j'avais un oncle un
an que dyer qui était excessivement
drôle cuir du fer du tiers qu'elle était
plus douée quoi qui a fait du cirque en
tout cas c'est déjà pas mal
et quand ils baisé la main d'une dame me
lever la patte arrière c'était pour
camoufler un peu il voulait être
probablement limitée des gens les hommes
qui étaient courtois et galant mais ça
le gêne à bruch d'être obligé de de
faire ce geste avril lever la pâte
il faisait pour rigoler alors évidemment
il faisait assez bien ça faisait rire
c'est un c'est ça et ça m'a paru comme
être le modèle de du comique qui se
dissimule pour pour moi je sais que moi
oui moi je
d'abord parce qu'on vous attaquent tout
de suite n'est ce pas moi à l'école je
ne voulais pas du tout faire le guignol
j'avais très peur des professeurs tout
ça je rentrais là avec le mal au ventre
j'avais peur tout le monde vous avez
peur à la douane parce que mon père
voyager beaucoup mais c'est franchir
beaucoup de douane l'auto quand mon père
francis le cordon sans s'arrêter si
j'arrivais la gare sans mon ticket je
tremblais je devrais toujours si ma mère
avait le ticket si j'avais en arrivant
en classe ce professeur défrayer j'avais
un mal à vraiment effrayant enfin
j'avais peur tout le temps tout le temps
et quand je suis a été à l'école j'ai vu
des enfants qui entendent demander ma
leçon qui rie et j'avais rien fait je
m'étais levé je voyais les enfants qui
régnait alors je finalement j'ai
accentué ce oui oui j'ai toujours j'ai
moins peur parce que j'ai pris une
espèce de métier je je maintenant je
connais un petit peu c'est à dire que je
me suis installé un peu dans dans le
comique alors je fais je fais je fais si
vous voulez le pitre d'une façon
beaucoup plus
à l'aise mais ça cache complètement
mavuba vraie nature qui est d'être très
timide très je dissimule ça comme ça et
beaucoup de comics sont des plus grands
comiques sont de très très grands qui
mise beaucoup plus timide que moi
puisqu'ils sont plus grands que moi